Cool. However, our network is spread across America or Black Jesuit alumni. It
would help for engagement continuously if there were, if it were to kind of
like establish like chapters, maybe city chapters because it's already
everything. So we had Jesuit Black alumni and Atlanta hosting and having certain
events. But we had Jesuit alumni in Birmingham doing things, DW doing certain
things. New Orleans just based on where these addresses are and where the
heat is shown that our members are and then reaching out and pulling them
together for maybe monthly, five months and even quarterly events to keep that
engagement going. It can become competitive and also lead up to you know our
Black alumni weekend. For example, I think that if we had something to
establish, I know for sure that I would be able to raise scholarship funds if it
was competitive in nature on the outside between somebody like me and Shannon
Shelby. So Shannon Shelby says he's over. He's now he's a social person. If he's
saying he's hosting something that a whole thing is it look like we're competing
but we're really not. We're raising money for the for the scholarship for the
scholarship fund. On the outside, it looks like me versus him. But for the same
purpose, it's over. Now we're taking it back to Jesuit days. It's an alpha versus
capital. But this is really my partner, right? But with but although we're getting
people linked in to this being a competitive thing, the overall end goal is
that we're raising money for the scholarship. So I would be tasked with putting
together my own event, right? And he might be doing his own event and it may be on
the same day. But see we both know how to build up that that interest over time and
see now when people see it the first time other people are going to want to
join in the competition. I owe I'm in this city doing this. Me and the alumni from
this city are doing this. You know, when if you're whether your event is
winning or losing, the scholarship is winning because all of our money is going
towards our scholarship, which is the big thing. So now when we're in the local
community, we're still tied in. We still have something we want to go home to,
but we're collectively building in so much money into the scholarship, which
gives us social capital with Jesuit to be able to request more because we are
giving more and we are participating more. Because Darren told me like, bro, our
issue is that we don't go and participate in the things that matter to Jesuit.
It's not always a matter of race. Sometimes it's a matter of money and what it is
that you are bringing to the university for them to give you resources. We
can't keep sitting here and when we do, not granted, we are contributors to
the scholarship, but things have grown over time. But for Darren to say, I'm on a
first-name basis with the university. I'm on a first-name basis with the
president of school. He said, I can call and say, hey, don't, why everybody got
security and we don't have security. He's like, I show up to the red tie
functions and do that. He's like, you guys got to participate more in the official
Jesuit things. He's like, it's not just the weekend. The Black alumni chapter
itself has a long history that predates the 90s. It's in the 90s that this
chapter was established. We don't put any honor to the history. We don't put any
honor to the founders. A lot of people don't know that the Black alumni network
is associated with the university. That the Black chapter, Black alumni chapter,
is associated with the university. They don't understand the inner
workings of how, hey, what we're doing is not just for a good time. What we're
doing is for scholarship. The university is not against us. In the least the
best. It's easy to assume that they don't want us to have anything or the DEI
but they do not care that we need resources. We still have Black alumni
weekend. We still was able to use the same name. They have not said, oh, we're
trying to get rid of it, but they would like to see more than what we are
doing. And no disrespect. Tyrone is not good at communicating that. Tyrone is
not good at communicating at all. And so I love Jamaica, but there are certain
things that Jamaica does not also understand as well. For example, I was saying,
hey, we need to actually have a separate Black alumni weekend page from Black
alumni network to disassociate that the Black alumni network only does the
weekend because it's kind of hard. We have people that show up to this weekend
who they graduate. We got people who just want to know about the party for us to
be keep mixing the two or the pages only active when x, y, and z happens. It's
an issue. She's not finished. I don't see why we should have two separate
pages. Well, maybe because you don't understand marketing, you're not thinking
from the customer perspective in working backwards. You're talking about what
you will like. You are tapped into this. Align old and this is this for the young
kids. No, there's only present. The only age is present today. There's some
caveats to it. But today is the age. Today is old is the age. So if most people
regardless of their age are going to this using these tools to get x, y, z and
this age bracket is using these tools and this age bracket is using these tools.
You cannot use this age brackets tools for this brackets tools. And it does not
work like that. However, we need to look at where the most participation is and
capitalize on that first and go from there. So you just gave a great caveat to what
we can segue to understanding about what we have around the data that exists in
order for us to be able to leverage what you've been able to explain. I asked the
question, you know, what do we have currently as a data set, for example, with the
Black Alumni Association or the Black Alumni Council to just see what we can do.
So I think of like, do we have, you spoke about like addresses? Do we have addresses?
If we have access, what access outside of addresses, do you think that we currently have
that we may be able to full numbers? Okay. Addresses. Okay. And I think that may be
enough in order for us to recognize like where we do have, is there anything that the
Alumni Association is doing for those that come for us to recognize if they in fact
are present for those that are current members. If that means like a check in for us to
say, okay, that current alumni member was there for this weekend, 2025. So we can
actually say, okay, we need to really say the gap exists for these areas versus those
that don't come or those that do come, right? Like, what can we leverage to do that because
I don't know what the end result or the product can be, but we at least know what data we have.
I guess the KPIs based on how much money comes in the scholarship based on these sponsorships
and tents that are purchased. Okay. What else? The attendance, but it's not like clocked.
So there's a lot of stuff that we don't have. There's a lot of, we like to call scrappy information
that we work with because some of these things are very simple concepts to me. What is going to make
somebody come? I have argued with these names for over five years to put the homecoming in
black alumni weekend on the same day. Why? Because when I would ask people why they wouldn't come,
they would say it's black alumni weekend and I didn't graduate. So for the record, our
fucking graduation rate and acceptance rate is a huge ass fucking disparity. The amount of people
who graduate from Jacksonville versus people who quit, the people who quit is way larger, right?
Anybody will come back to a homecoming because in order to come to a homecoming,
all you had to do was attend. Graduation is not a requirement of attendance, but when you throw
alumni in there, that just means graduation, right? So there's a segment where we was doing
homecoming one weekend. We was doing black alumni another weekend. We have one black crowd and now
we split it in half. In the day and age where optics are everything, okay? If this room only
holds 100 people and we got 50 in and on this weekend and 50 on this weekend, it looks lame as
fuck. But if we put all 100 in there and that 100 room, it looks pretty got them lit.
And now we're creating a photo for people the previous year. So when you look at a marketing
perspective, calling it, let's just say calling it black alumni weekend, ostracizes those
that weren't alone. Which is why after so many fucking arguments, it's on the same weekend. So you
will see JSU, black alumni weekend, line, homecoming. Now, so now you got the call to both parties.
So we solved that problem. That's solved. But I had to fight back and forth with even with your
ego, even with Tyrone and keep having to break it down to you guys are thinking about y'all.
I am going to have conversations with people. Granted, one of the benefits of me being in Jacksonville
and it's taken forever for me to get my fucking degree is knowing hella fucking people.
And then living in the area and seeing people who were still in school after I graduated,
to still have some kind of connection because they know my face. But to solicit their feedback
and do something with it, I'm not making this about me, it's about the scholarship. So if you're
telling me what puts money in the scholarship, attendance, address attendance, but makes you attend
this or that, this make me feel good, this make me feel bad. Well, what if it was at the same
down time? Well, shit, now I feel good because my guard is down and I could just see my friends and
now it's nostalgic and it's fun and now we have a range of things. People are not thinking like that.
I have to tell Tyrone, Jalisa, and it's on case of Jamega, that's my dog. Love what it does.
We are not planning the event for us. We're gonna need to do whatever the fuck it is that we need
to do to put the money in the scholarship because at the end of the day, we need this scholarship to
help other black students get through fucking college. So let's go. So what haven't we solved?
Now that we solved the problem of a homecoming in black alumni weekends, not being in the same
date, but now they are. What haven't we solved? Streamline will want continuous engagement
throughout the year before leading up like a couple months, right? Absolutely. Okay. We are not,
we struggle with continuous engagement. If I'm not on the black alumni page, damn there ain't
nobody, if nothing's happened. Like I got on what was it? 27, 10, or maybe I got to pass where it
2021. I'm like, nigga, do you realize we got 300 fucking followers? Who the fuck was spent
a concert at shit? Yeah. I'm like, nobody. Go and comment on people's another issue that we had.
Was the hashtag JSU. That's Jacksonville State and that's Jackson State. So going on and I'm taking
the time, me understanding how this works, clicking the hashtag, taking the time to go post through
post, adding, commenting, graduates, that's fire, fire emojis, ooh, love it, tea, whatever, whatever,
who I'm talking about in it, whatever to boost the engagement because that's what people value.
Like, oh, people want to feel like, oh, this is my friend. Oh, that page lit. Like even when I
respond to certain people through the page, like sometimes I might have to make a joke or whatever,
whatever, like you can tell, like I got the joke side, I got to hate this to professional,
but it's the engagement. Even when somebody brings the idea to me that I feel like it's trash,
instead of saying no, or we can't do it, like I might let you talk all the way through it,
but then also tell you like, this is what we need to do. This is what we need. But also letting
you know that this, we are a university organization. This is not straight hustling. And we're not
planning for 231. And then we do have to have approvals and that the university is not going to allow
us to just slap JSU on anything, right? So that's the thing. So letting people know that,
because fucking Kiera camera or key bus and whatever the fuck, the SG roll key. She said she didn't
know that black alumni in that chapter was a part of the school. She just thought it was just
on random black people pushing it together. Okay, but in another segment, when is it that we're
putting out there less people know that that's not the case. Don't you see nothing's agency? But
look at this. Granted, the black alumni chapter actually has a valuable history and notable
members. And it was established in 1996. We literally should be able to do something with
level of way of promoting and giving homage to that where that is like a part of the
the site or the page is like, Hey, when you come here, this is the intro, like you should be able to
to see this annually, like we're going to give you this again as it relates to this is why and who
we are and how it became like that's something. But what else other than the one that I did that I
had this shit fucking pissed me off because I thought I communicated this well. We needed a cycle
of service. So for me, as somebody who's a part of black alumni chapter, black alumni network now,
because the university has gone away from chapters, it just caught network. So it could be whatever
whatever network. So I didn't know the black alumni network was a thing until 2021. That is fucking
seven years I thought graduated from the university. However, this thing has been out
damn near 20 years before I graduated, right? Why is it that I only knew about this
until after I graduated years at an event? My thing is to create a cycle. Why not facilitate a future
black alumni organization on campus so that there is a mental transition that when I joined in
college, I am a future black alumni association member, whatever future black alumni network member.
So when I move on and graduate, I understand that black alumni is a thing. It's indoctrinated
and subconsciously planted in my mind to make me move forward. Which means that that same future
black alumni organization on campus needs to engage with the current black alumni network to have
partner the events of something to engage with the current what we see after what offer is
in partnership to make it worthwhile that if we establish the organization and it has officers
that they can get a scholarship for being a part of the executive body of the organization
okay there is an incentive and we offer on the black alumni side networking and mentorship.
When we have not done very well at all of the black alumni network is cultivation of leadership
and mentors of people who actively want to do something and actually have these skills and
criteria like skill, knowledge, wisdom and intent to want to do something valuable. Now I talk
about equity here and I look at we look at executive members as being those leaders that's the
upper deletion line now. There are those that may not want to be in leadership roles they'd like
to be behind the scenes and all. What can we offer or what in the sense of for those that are
non leadership members, what can the black alumni network offer those students as well as the
executive students where they also feel developed, they also feel invested, they also feel that there
is an incentive to join this organization and also continue after graduation and joined the
black alumni network. We have to be able to find a bridge right in order for them to also feel
there's a legacy to even deal. And on the alumni side I feel like that exists but when people are
sending us retards it's kind of fucking hard. Okay so let's talk about what exists. What exists
currently then? For them. A.K.S.I. not talking about shit. When we was in school Niggas was having
a pledge classes 20, 30 plus now I see they're having four eight seven two one. What equity
there exists now then with A.K.S.I. we didn't need none because I still don't see A.K.S.I doing
nothing though we never needed none. We never needed A.K.S.I. okay but it wasn't it was something that
was still beneficial. How? Because most people if you had joined A.K.S.I understand organizational
structure and leadership to know that you play a part in it there's a upfront accountability system
and an upfront process quote unquote. There's a there's a point A to point B. I hate to use a word
process. When somebody tells me that they've been a part of a group that has an organizational
structure it's not hard for me to believe that they can transition into the next organization
because they understand there's fucking structure and things to be done if they've been on a committee
whatever they know that this person says this I do this we do this you take a person that don't
understand or know any of that shit then you try to put it in something like what we have
it's not gonna work out. So I'm gonna tell you this from a management perspective now we're
both in the careers and I will tell you this if you did not have your own boarding processes in
place you're failing so if we as an organization do not have hey here is an intro to an organization
structure framework and we know that that is imperative for someone that joins my organization
our organization in order to be effective we should create a process or a training in order
for them to understand what they do not have and we should not rely on a separate organization
or the entity to be able to provide that because maybe that is not the path that they're going because
I don't want think about it someone to join in auxiliary to join mine when we can provide the
training for them directly look at this so what do we do let me hit you with this I agree with
you a thousand percent but before you get the onboard niggas want to have a interview and know
what your previous experience is before you can even get in the fucking door so on the same
thing we're looking at previous experiences is it something we can work with it's very rare there
are some people who was just motherfucking Michael Jordan of the trap where they can come in to
assimilate and play and make that thing like but they'd be like you wasn't XYZ organized uh uh
yeah not fuck no but I also still believe that even if we know that we in our interview that we
have that available to be able to decipher or discern like okay they have the capability of your
capacity if we still don't have something directly related to us we're still failed absolutely
absolutely absolutely one and I think that even though you may have been in a case I you may
have been in this year you may have been somewhere you've seen certain frameworks you've seen
parliamentary procedure but I want you to go through with Zi Zi well whoever is doing because if you
don't but we are failing because we're our expectation it's awful of something that is
absolutely faux in fact right that even when you tie it into yeah I've been in a case I
but nigga ain't never been to no meeting but we but okay but we that's crazy now I'm saying that's
the truth I wasn't I wasn't I was in edge I was in a case I and since since I thought after
on the court I never went to another meeting after you became after after I became an alpha but yeah
that's cool but I will say this my line brother then and I promise you he don't know nothing about
man I know what's not going to shit you asked that man what's the role of a vice president you
wouldn't know I mean but it was so how do we be able to create a knowledge bank to be able to
give somebody acumen around the smallest and intro level then tell you this bro and it's going
to sound fucked up and I have this compositional cloud until we offer insert when it comes to
leadership and influence not leadership too now you got to include them it's there by
and large the majority of the organization come on now you can think about it they're the ones
that actually pay for and keep operations open and run leadership yeah my leadership the
organizations still have to remain exclusive for sure and it cannot that we don't things don't
be vetted sometimes it'd be people like oh my god but we're we're wanting non-leaders to
insert in capacities I don't like like I still feel like that non-leaders have to understand and
know enough to know like okay this is what we supposed to do as non-leaders in our expectations
with those leaders should be clear so nothing else what we have to do is realize and I think this
ties back into like the black alumni stuff is like we have to recognize what we went from them
and what they need from us and so what we can do with the data that we have with the black alumni
network we can provide a compass for those that are assume leaders or those that volunteer as
leaders to do something for the black alumni network in order to engage and connect and reclaim
those that have not been to homecoming black alumni weekends et cetera especially for those
that have not been contributed to any scholarship that we've had the thing is there the
shouldn't be going on is that the people who want and so much out of our out of our black alumni
network and contributed a fucking dime they don't know how anything fucking works not from a
practical like not even the basic practical ship like even the other day I had a somebody
message to page I entertain a conversation I entertain the conversation one because I don't
want you to feel like if you speak to the network that you're going to get brushed off and nobody
will hear you out right just like hey so what's your idea that I okay what are you wanting to do
and till they get to the point in the conversation I say so are you wanting to facilitate this
financial deal or were you expecting the black alumni network to finance this there's like oh I was
just looking to you know how coordinate okay coach now what you said was not a bad way to
respond to what I can recommend is how you deliver that message the way that I say that
I want to let me let me let me let me read it so you know I'm just saying what the way that you
said and everything that you have I like the context this is why I would have been able to respond
to that instead I would have said I love the idea and what you been able to bring as I was doing
my research I understand that there is some assume cost that we would have to incur that I want
to know what is your ideas on how we can do this never says the first I need some older as
HM and I'm like obviously you ain't plugged in with the goals because I'm never heard of you
sends me to Vegas Greek picnic weekend okay he said hey I was thinking this event would be a
great idea to continue to build the brother and sisterhood not only at JSU but also nationally
I live in Vegas and I can assist in coordinating I said what's your idea of what it would look
like for JSU it said we could set up accommodation and JSU holds an events at lounges or restaurants
I said in Vegas or are you thinking about just hosting alumni events outside of the weekend in
different places say yes while still having our annual event in JV I see this as an opportunity
to continue to build on with it's already going well to JSU I am sure several alumni would be
coming will be coming to Vegas so why not have the JSU hosted events to attend I said sounds
like a good idea we're actually looking to try to have more events throughout the year aside from
Black alumni weekend I will say that the biggest barrier is complaints from alumni and community
members about cost it'll take some work but I don't think it's impossible he said exactly that's
why I believe it's a great opportunity to piggyback off this Greek weekend in Vegas you don't
need to sell Vegas to anyone because it sells itself however he's selling sales it's S-A-L-E-S
I said oh you're saying to do it the same weekend as this Greek weekend he said yes just like you
mentioned you're looking to do other events throughout the year and that weekend is perfect to host
something I said do you have the average cost of a hotel in flight there for the weekend and what
of this JSU Black alumni network would be hosting or supporting is this something that you will be
facilitating financially or is this something that you're expecting the JSU Black alumni network to
take care of no I was simply suggesting an offering to a system coordinate this how the fuck we
don't have a whole event no one and no nothing I said understood we definitely have we definitely
have to have a lot of that information up front to build an event like that I think it's a good idea
it just has a lot of working pieces including university approval and funding he said as expected
just give me a list of things you need to know in order to pull this off and I see what I can do
this is your idea instead I just said so we would need a formal business proposal we would have
to present this to the exec board and then the exec board have to present this to the university
because we can't use JSU's name or trademarks without approval and we also need approval for the
funding what I need is a clear overview of what you're proposing that includes the type of events
the point of context responsible for planning the execution proposed dates and times and locations
and a complete cost picture specifically estimated attendance itemized cost average hotels rate
estimated airfare estimated income or revenue model hosts confirm photographer and videographer
with cost and turnaround times the marketing plan venue policies and restrictions and other
event insurance costs once that information is outlined we can evaluate feasibility and alignment
and move forward accordingly this nigga said I'll see what I can put together and get back to you
I said back sounds good big chance what the fuck you thought I was gonna do with a flyer nigga and
the idea